hello everybody markiplier here with my
thousand subscriber milestone video
exactly three weeks ago I submitted my
first video to zero subscribers and now
you guys have gotten me 2,000
subscribers faster than I ever thought
possible
so to celebrate I'm gonna do the
cinnamon challenge okay you didn't know
that cinnamon challenge is where you try
to eat or swallow a tablespoon of
cinnamon in 60 seconds without any water
in one go and if you also know about
this challenge
not many people succeed so music
regulation tablespoon of cinnamon and
I've got my emergency throat evacuator
of water here so all right if you're
ready I am now Louisville that was
terrible that's a thing I've ever done
myself ah thank you guys so much for
watching hope you enjoyed that I'm never
gonna do it again
ah but anyway hopefully though the
Goodenough celebration for you guys
thank you so much for watching i'm gonna
do more stupid stuff like this if you
want me to so if you want to see more
stupid human tricks write in the
comments suggest me for something to do
and i'll doing out another subscriber
milestone or i'll just do it so thank
you guys so much for subscribing to my
channel and keep watching because i'm
always gonna keep posting videos if
you're gonna keep watching it so thank
you again and i will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh